welcome to your first day of being a
waitress hell starts in three two
one
[Music]
and I'm just gonna assume that you don't
have a reservation Akana reminds us all
why it's easier to eat at home
restaurant staff go through enough and
it just seems chaotic hey Welcome to The
Cheesecake Factory table for two right
it's about a one to two day wait okay
lunch restaurants the place is awesome
oh and take this this buzzer will
self-destruct once your tables ready
though I am craving Cheesecake Factory
right about now
[Music]
I'll be back within an hour or seven
okay
[Music]
anything else I can get you before I
disappear into the unknown for all
maternities